pour mettre tout le monde de bonne
humeur ou pour faire sourire le
président à distance donc chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs alors
avant je voudrais prendre toutes les
précautions d'usage il m'arrive parfois
de décorer des noms de famille ou des
prénoms et là je pense que la tâche est
plus difficile pour moi donc si je le
fais je vous prie de m'excuser par avant
nous poursuivons ce matin nos travaux
sur la parentalité dans les outre-mer en
commun par nos deux délégations la
délégation aux outre-mer précisée par
Stéphane Artano qui est chez lui dans
son territoire et la délégation au droit
des femmes que j'ai l'honneur de
présider et nous sommes ici nombreux en
salle de réunion au Sénat donc en
présentiel également outre les
présidents des deux délégations sont
également rapporteurs sur cette
thématique mais de voisines elles
achètent et victoire jasmin si certains
constats sont communs ont différents
territoires d'outre-mer chacun présente
évidemment c'est particularités c'est
pourquoi nous organisons des tables
rondes régionales consacré à chaque
bassin de territoire nous nous
intéressons ce matin au collectivités du
Pacifique
Nouvelle-Calédonie Polynésie française
et Wallis-et-Futuna nous entendons par
visioconférence monsieur munipose et
Mounia caca j'espère que tout va bien
jusque là président de l'Assemblée
territoriale de wallisée Futuna madame
Kia liqui la gikula présidente de la
commission conditions féminine de
l'Assemblée territoriale de
Wallis-et-Futuna madame Isabelle leblic
docteur en anthropologie sociale et
culturelle directrice de recherche au
CNRS et puis également madame Stéphanie
Geneix rabot maîtresse de conférence en
sciences de langage à l'Université de
Nouvelle-Calédonie responsables du
projet Petit Campus
monsieur Loïs bastide maître de
conférence en sociologie à l'Université
de la Polynésie française chercher à la
Maison des sciences de l'homme du
Pacifique et Madame Rodica highlandka
peut-être Kaï je ne sais pas professeur
des universités enseignantes chercheurs
à l'Institut National Supérieur du
professeur rat et de l'éducation de
Polynésie française directrice du
laboratoire et
et
Isco oui c'est mieux c'est facile
Isco société traditionnelle et
contemporaine en Océanie à la fois les
noms de famille et les acronymes sont
toujours une difficulté bienvenue à vous
et merci pour votre disponibilité jour
et nuit donc puisque 4h du matin pour le
président Artano donc les sénateurs sont
H24 disponibles c'est la preuve en
images ce matin l'objectif de cette
table ronde est double premièrement
examiner ce que recouvre la notion de
famille dans les îles de Pacifique les
évolutions d'être structures familiales
les rôles des mers perd grands-parents
et autres membres de la famille ainsi
que la question de la circulation des
enfants fréquentes dans les sociétés
traditionnelles Canac et polynésienne
deuxièmement examiner les actions de
soutien à la parentalité mise en place
par les collectivités de nouvelles
collines de nids Polynésie française et
wallis-et-futun sachant que ces
collectivités d'outre-mer sont autonomes
en matière de politique familiale et
sociales il est toujours intéressant
pour nous de prendre connaissance de ces
initiatives mises en place localement
dans vos territoires afin d'envisager de
les dupliquer ailleurs je laisse sans
plus tarder la parole à mon collègue
Stéphane Artano président de la
Délégation aux outre-mer qui intervient
à distance depuis
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon à un horaire
très très matinal 4 heures du matin mais
peut-être que lorsqu'il rejoint son
territoire de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
peut-être que c'est une habitude pour
lui de se coucher à 4h du matin et qui
on va le vérifier en images si c'est si
tu es en forme cher président
un nouveau président Gérard Larcher
d'avoir permis au tramarin de continuer
à pouvoir se connecter en
visioconférence pour toutes nos
auditions c'est quand même un outil qui
est très utile qui lui permet notamment
de d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui et
surtout de pouvoir prendre la parole
maintenant salut depuis mon territoire
et je participe présent donc vous l'avez
vu en visioconférence à cette table
ronde sur la parentalité dans le
Pacifique je m'excuse évidemment auprès
de mes collègues rapporteur d'être à
distance comme vous cher Annick que je
me félicite de cette opportunité
d'appréhender les notions de famille
élargie d'adoption de réseau de parents
à ce stade de travaux je remercie nos
intervenants et intervenantes qui
connaissent particulièrement bien ses
réalités de nos trois collectivités du
Pacifique nous aider à entrer dans les
subtilités des réalités sociologiques
des territoires qui ont leur propre
culture et de fortes identité ces
sociétés qu'elles soient d'ailleurs
polynésiennes ou millanésiennes sont
aussi impactés par la modernité je pense
qu'on va l'évoquer il nous est
particulièrement
utile dans ce cadre mesdames et
messieurs savoir vos différents points
de vue sur l'évolution des rapports au
sein des familles dans des sociétés
issues d'autres traditions que celles
que nous avons notamment dans l'Hexagone
je suis également particulièrement très
heureux de saluer le président de
l'Assemblée territoriale de
Wallis-et-Futuna
mouniaka que j'ai eu le plaisir
d'accueillir au Sénat il y a maintenant
quelques mois dans le cadre d'une autre
étude sur l'évolution institutionnelle
que nous avons souhaité mener et
d'autres sujets comme la continuité
territoriale dont nous venons de rendre
un rapport je vais m'en arrêter là
chaque présidente et je te laisse le
soin avec une collègue rapporteur de
pouvoir piloter cette obsession
si jamais j'ai des questions pour ceux
qui nous font plaisir d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup président donc écoutez les
premiers intervenants de cette table
ronde ce sont les représentants de
l'Assemblée territoriale de wallisée
Futuna monsieur muni poésie Mounia caca
et Madame
qui a Liki là j'ai coula donc vous allez
nous présenter tous les deux les
particularités des structures familiales
et parentales à wallisée Futuna
l'organisation des politiques familiales
ainsi que les actions en matière de
soutien à la parentalité qui existe sur
votre territoire et qui gagnera
peut-être à you qui gagnera y être
développé donc je vous laisse comme vous
le souhaitez organiser votre temps de
parole merci chers Stéphane pour ces
propos et à vous
à vous Wallis et Futuna
alors faut brancher les micros
et
pour vous avancer
présenter les salutations les plus
respectueuses
le président de la
validation des Outre-mer mais aussi à
vous madame la Présidente bien sûr de
séance
qui préside justement
cette réunion que ça soit en
en visio ou en présentiel donc
[Musique]
pour
pour le territoire des îles je pense que
le sujet en question c'est à dire sur la
parentalité
[Musique]
on va vous développer
car il s'effectue en trois volets c'est
à dire sur les parties de la réalité des
structeurs
familiales et parentale d'avoir
également une organisation des
politiques familiales et nous allons
bien sûr terminé avec les actions en
matière de soutien à la parentalité et
ma collègue élue
madame
santé
elle ne serait pas
présente avec avec nous pour cette
réunion sinon nous avons deux élus bien
sûr de foutoulants ils sont ici présents
avec nous et pour la présentation de
je vous propose de je laisserai à ma
charger de mission
de vous présenter bien sûr de sujet
s je vous remercie
bonjour
à tout le monde alors pour ce qui est là
de toute façon madame la Présidente je
vais vous envoyer après la
note parce que j'ai été claire quand
j'ai répondu justement à votre mail en
vous disant que pour moi c'est plus là
ce sera une présentation une
présentation électrique alors les
particularités des structures familiales
et les parentales seront
laissé tout à la notion de famille au
sens au sens défini justement par l'IMC
à savoir le couple les parents et le et
enfants et plus vous avez aussi cette
particularité qui est on a des familles
élargies donc qui comprend les
grands-parents donc les hommes du
premier degré et leur descendance des
conjoints les tout ce qui est
le grand-parents et entre le tente et
même le même la nounou et
toutes les personnes qui viennent en
aide à l'éducation de l'enfant pourquoi
parce que la notion de famille ici sur
un lycée
un plan et donc et dans ces différents
plans vous avez un chef de cette les
grands-parents parce qu'on a toujours
cette ce respect justement parce que
c'est eux qui véhicule justement les et
qui transmet
et transmettent le savoir-faire et tout
ce qui est coutume et traditions pour
aller chez coutuma
on a aussi la présence de plusieurs
familles que nos parentsales et tout ça
apparaissent par suite des divorces et
aussi des couples sans enfance
il faut savoir aussi qu'on a ici des
maisons traditionnelles
à les appels localement des palais et
tout ces familles composées justement je
faisais parler tout à l'heure habite
dans les sous le même toit donc vous
avez même jusqu'à la quatrième
génération
il existe aussi ici des communautés
comme dans tout notre mère des
communautés des expatriés ou détachés
des principalement
fondés sur le sur le système
métropolitain
alors le deuxième point sur
l'organisation des politiques familiales
dans le rôle des parents ici sur Wallis
et Futuna sont plus conservateurs et
traditionalistes
alors comme je disais tout à l'heure le
rôle des grands-parents est tout aussi
important parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus
grande place dans l'éducation et surtout
la transmission des savoirs et des
valeurs notamment pour ce qui est du
respect des priorités de vie des
traditions de la culture des travaux à
la maison et aux champs envers les plus
jeunes
les interactions plus ou moins proches
d'une noyau principal
à savoir le couple parents encore au
sens au sens métropolitain parce que
c'est un interaction on peut c'est quasi
quotidienne et certains angles étant mal
le relais sur les parents biologiques
alors l'autorité parentale du noyau
principal recouvre l'ensemble des droits
et des devoirs des parents à l'égard de
leurs enfants mineurs ils doivent élever
la notion de protection n'est apparue
que très récemment aussi bien
physiquement que moralement sur les
écouteurs chaque parent accompagné des
grands-parents transmet les informations
sur le droit continuer la tradition la
culture coutume au plus jeune en
fonction de son âge et de ce et de son
genre donc l'organisation politique
aussi il faut savoir que ici c'est la
spécificité d'avoir un chef pays c'est à
dire qu'ils occupe quand même un rôle
assez étant sur le
l'éducation et l'évolution justement de
d'un enfant
alors le troisième point sur les actions
en matière de soutien à la parentalité
nombre de services territoriaux oeuvres
pour les enfants et les jeunes à avoir
laissé toute une heure on a par exemple
tout le pôle social et donc on retrouve
le service du sitas
on a l'agence de santé
qui travaille notamment sur la
prévention on a une série dynamique et
gérée par le pôle des sages-femmes on a
le district aura et ladek
pour tous les établissements scolaires
il y a le réseau d'infirmières scolaires
et de référence vous allez beaucoup
d'associations de parents d'élèves donc
mais ce sont des systèmes qui restent
renforcer
le rôle aussi important de la déléguer
au droit des femmes qui intervient au
sein du pôle social et notamment et en
France
victimes victimes de violence
et alors on a la Fédération du handicap
de Wally seckuna les différentes
associations
les associations sportives aussi
et puis tout ce qui a semblé
territoriale l'administration supérieure
et le tribunal et la gendarmerie
les gars on a un rôle phare aussi c'est
qui est donné un organisme aussi
c'est l'Église il faut savoir que que si
on relie ces Futuna l'Église a un rôle
important donc à travers des actions et
les messages qui fait passer
notamment au travers des messes donc
c'est aussi
un référent qui rassemble tous ces
jeunes
toutes les catégories sociales et
s'adapter à leur niveau de compréhension
et d'intégration et pouvoir être mise en
place pour tous les âges aussi bien pour
les très jeunes parents que les plus
âgés mais aussi pour les enfants en
quelque soit leur âge il y a
un déficit de la communication liée à la
censure inhérente au système familial et
social les conflits sont réguliers au
sein des familles et on extra familial
tout comme les violences intracamelles
extra familiales le mal-être lié au
problème de l'adolescence dans un
conduitariste augmente
on a des informations et formation
concrètes aux outils numériques et
réseaux sociaux sont nécessaires sur
notre territoire aussi bien auprès des
parents
de lâcher prise envers les enfants
on a l'application donc je disais
l'application de notre coutume à travers
notre chefferie qui est nécessaire et
très importante alors les actions à
développer dans un premier temps une
approche globale est nécessaire pour
informer la population du cibler par
site par village par exemple des actions
et des lieux d'échange aussi pour la
création de médiateurs sociaux de
proximité dans certains seraient issus
de la circuit mise en place centrale
d'action et de soutien en faveur de la
création des conflits au sein des
familles dans la coutume et sur l'espace
public nous sommes restructuration via
une augmentation de personnels qualifiée
et salariés et nécessaire notamment au
sein du pôle social du sitas au sein de
la déesse Paul petite enfance avec la
création d'une PMI quotidienne une
maison de la petite enfance et au sein
du pôle prévention coordination entre
les services et avec les obligations est
obligatoire une meilleure communication
ou la mise en place d'un schéma plan de
structuration et les interventions
communes sont nécessaires une réflexions
globale à croissance 60 degrés avec un
plan d'action générale et commune et
associations incluant les lacunes du
territoire et ses absences de structure
doit être portée la mise en place d'une
politique sociale adaptée
notamment en matière technologique tout
ce site internet les enfants on a encore
la part de la des parents qui est énorme
parce que il faut savoir qu'ici avoir
les exceptionnelles les mêmes les
adultes sont considérés comme des
enfants parce que il reste dans le foyer
familial jusqu'à
30 pour 40 ans
merci
est-ce que vous aviez d'autres personnes
qui souhaitent intervenir depuis votre
salle de réunion pour compléter ce
propos ou c'est ok pour vous
je vous enverrai après la présentation
et bien écoutez merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces précisions et vous nous avez
permis de cadrer un petit peu mieux ce
qui était la parentalité sur votre
territoire et donc je vais tout de suite
immédiatement donner la parole à madame
Isabelle leblic directrice de recherche
ocnrs pour une présentation des
particularités de la parentalité en
Nouvelle-Calédonie un éclairage sur le
sujet de la circulation des enfants dans
les sociétés Canac et polynésiennes vous
nous direz également quelles
conséquences vous en tirez quant aux
besoins en matière de soutien à la
parentalité elle est nécessaire
adaptation des politiques familiales et
donc nous avons notre collègue sénateur
qui est également présent Gérard podia
avec nous en salle à Paris au Sénat
oui bonjour merci à vous de m'avoir
sollicité pour intervenir
je tiens à dire que mes travaux sur la
famille et l'adoption des enfants
date de quelques années maintenant donc
je n'ai pas de de vision actuelle de ce
qui se passe dans Nouvelle-Calédonie en
Polynésie française puisque c'est des
travaux que je n'ai pas pu continuer
pour diverses raisons de manque de
retour sur le terrain
comme il a été présenté avant moi pour
Wallis-et-Futuna et donc pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie que comme pour la
Polynésie française on aura des
structures familiales très similaires
avec justement une parenté
classification des parentés élargies et
pas simplement un couple de famille
nucléaire comme on retrouve chez nous
parents et enfants
c'est ces modèles qui sont largement
répandus encore en Nouvelle-Calédonie
bien qu'il faille il faut faire des
différences territoriales bien sûr entre
le Grand Nouméa et puis l'intérieur et
les îles où on a des contextes
différents temps au niveau de
l'urbanisation qu'au niveau des modes de
vie travail salarié ou non qui influent
grandement aujourd'hui sur ces modèles
parentaux
donc comme il a été dit précédemment
pendant au lycée Futuna c'est des
parents qui sont très linagères et donc
qui associe dans les familles bien sûr
il y a les parents de naissance des
enfants mais il y a aussi tout le groupe
des papas et tous les groupes de mamans
qui sont les sœurs de mer pour les
mamans les frères de père pour les papas
dans d'autres enfin selon les régions
cahier de nuit c'est même plus large
parce que ça inclut aussi tous les
oncles
des deux côtés ça dépend des systèmes de
parenté dans les sociétés canal qu'on a
pu observer
donc tous ces personnes interviennent
de façon traditionnelle dans le soin
apporté aux enfants l'éducation des
enfants la transmission orale comme il a
été aussi d'un certain nombre de savoir
même si aujourd'hui c'est différentes
choses
ont tendance à diminuer de par
l'influence du modèle de société
occidentales la télévision
l'Internet tout ça qui fait que les
enfants peut-être pas loin de temps
maintenant avec leurs grands-parents qui
étaient en charge de cette transmission
le plus souvent que c'était par le passé
mais cela n'empêche pas que les règles
en tout cas en société kanak les règles
les rythmes de vie sont sont
rythmées enfin la vie est rythmée par un
certain nombre de cérémonies qui vont de
la naissance jusqu'au deuil et qui sont
des choses qui sont importantes
aujourd'hui et qui rappellent les liens
entre les individus les groupes les
familles les clans et qui sont toujours
très actifs
donc il faut aussi différencier pour la
Calédonie les
familles qui ressortent du statut
coutumier des familles qui sont de droit
commun puisque en Nouvelle-Calédonie
nous avons les deux statuts toujours le
statut coutumier qui concerne les
au sens large des canards qui est le
statut de droit commun qui concerne
toutes les
populations arrivées par la colonisation
en Nouvelle-Calédonie donc
tous les parents donc dans les familles
Ghana qui ont un rôle important les
prises en charge peuvent être multiples
en ville c'est sûr que ça repose plus
sur la parenté restreinte que quand on
est dans ce qu'on appelle des tribus en
Nouvelle-Calédonie ou ou l'habitat est
beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus familiale et même si on a
maintenant la tendance à avoir des
maisons individuelles par famille
les habitats sont proches les uns des
autres et donc on n'est jamais loin de
grands-parents
donc de tentes etc qui interviennent
dans la vie des enfants en ville bien
entendu maintenant on passe plus par le
système de de d'un gardiennage extérieur
que ça soit des nourrices des systèmes
de garderie etc qui prennent en soi des
enfants pendant que les parents
travaillent dans la petite enfance
donc
après alors en ce qui concerne la
circulation des enfants donc là aussi
comme dans de nombreuses sociétés
océaniennes les sociétés Canac
polynésiennes avaient une circulation
traditionnelle des enfants
qui se passait soit dans la pas dans le
lignage dans la parenté proche soit dans
une parenté élargi par l'Alliance il y a
de multiples il y avait de multiples
raisons pour ces circulations d'enfants
qui n'étaient pas simplement l'adoption
n'était pas comme chez nous juste pour
pallier à un manque de descendance mais
ça pouvait être beaucoup d'autres
raisons qui présidaient à cette
circulation
aujourd'hui ça
c'est quelque chose qui est encore très
important en Nouvelle-Calédonie moi
quand j'ai mes fait mes études à Pony
rywoins j'avais un quart des enfants
recensés dans les généalogies qui
avaient fait l'objet d'un transfert
d'enfant ce qui fait quand même une part
importante alors il faut savoir que en
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est d'adoptions se
font de façon par les par le statut
civil le statut coutumier qu'elles n'ont
pas besoin de passer comme chez nous par
des jugements
pour les transferts de parenté
dans la région j'ai travaillé dans
plusieurs régions qui allaient donner il
y a pas de secret adoptif les parents
circulent aussi bien dans la dans leur
famille de naissance que dans leur
famille adoptive et on procède le plus
souvent par cumul de filiation
donc ça c'est quelque chose d'important
moi je n'ai travaillé qu'avec des
enfants des des adultes ayant été
adoptés pendant leur enfance ou quand
ils étaient bébés
je n'ai pas travaillé avec des enfants
au moment où ils étaient adoptés parce
que les règles de travail avec les
enfants sont tout à fait particulières
et ça nécessite une méthodologie qu'on
n'a pas forcément nous en tant
qu'anthropologue par contre j'ai observé
des enfants adoptés dans leur milieu
d'adoption qui ne qui
naviguaient tout à fait entre leurs
familles respectives
la différence que je verrai fondamentale
entre l'adoption en Nouvelle-Calédonie
l'adoption un peu de musique française
et le fait que la Polynésie française a
inséré l'adoption dans l'adoption
internationale puisqu'il y a beaucoup
d'adoption par des couples
métropolitains de France sans enfant qui
vont qui ont été en Polynésie adopter
des enfants
dans un système le plus souvent
d'adoption ouverte c'est-à-dire que avec
des retours enfin c'est comme ça qu'au
départ les contrats étaient passés avec
les familles qui donnaient leurs enfants
assez couple des retours réguliers des
enfants sur la Polynésie
donc ça aussi c'est quelque chose de
c'est une donnée difficile importante à
prendre en compte
donc l'articulation du droit civil est
droit commun du droit coutumier c'est
aussi quelque chose
qui est de compétence donc
du territoire de nouvelle de la
collectivité de Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est
quelque chose qui est toujours un peu
difficile c'est à dire que moi dans le
temps quand j'ai enfin il y a 30 ans
maintenant quand j'ai travaillé sur ces
questions là il y avait souvent une
incompréhension des interventions
sociales sur ce qui était l'adoption en
milieu Canac par exemple et on avait
tendance à plaquer nos modèles de
référence
le fait que les enfants étaient détachés
de leurs parents que ça faisait des
traumatismes c'est des choses qui sont
qui peuvent exister je dis pas que ça
n'existe pas du tout en milieu canal
mais c'est pas on peut pas en faire des
généralités comme ça
aujourd'hui toute le secteur de
l'intervention sociale et quand même un
par rapport toujours en
Nouvelle-Calédonie on manque de de
d'intervenants qui sont issus des
différentes sociétés calédoniennes parce
qu'il y a là je parle des Kanaks
essentiellement mais en Calédonie il y a
énormément de sociétés d'origine
différente des Tahitiens les Wallisiens
il rien les les Vietnamiens les Japonais
enfin les Javanais c'est il y a une
diversité de de communautés qui fait que
qu'il y a des des modèles différents je
pourrais pas généraliser à l'ensemble de
la Nouvelle-Calédonie
comme je l'ai été prévenu que samedi
pour aujourd'hui je n'ai pas pu étudier
où on était les politiques familiales
aujourd'hui en Nouvelle-Calédonie donc
je pouvais pas vous répondre sur la
question je pense que pour pouvoir
étudier ça de plus en
plus avant et puisque le but aussi de
votre commission et de faire des lois
qui sont tournés vers l'Outre-mer c'est
quand même de pouvoir avoir des
interventions directement de personnes
investies en Nouvelle-Calédonie de ces
questions là qui pourront vous répondre
plus avant parce que là c'est moi je
n'ai qu'une vision extérieure et en plus
peut-être daté je ne sais pas je ne peux
l'import ance des liens familiaux est
toujours vivaces ça c'est certain
maintenant
je ne peux pas vous dire ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui sur un certain nombre de
questions et notamment sur le Grand
Nouméa puisque moi je n'ai pas travaillé
sur le Grand Nouméa j'ai travaillé que
dans l'intérieur et dans les îles
merci beaucoup madame bien entendu une
telle réunion avec des territoires aussi
divers c'était difficile à monter et
c'est pour cette raison que vous avez
été évidemment prévenu peut-être un
petit peu tardivement nous nous en
excusons mais si vous souhaitez apporter
une contribution complémentaire par
écrit nous l'apprendrons avec grand
plaisir donc je souhaite aussi préciser
que nous avons en salle avec nous ce
matin des sénateurs des territoires
ultramarins dont nous parlons évidemment
le sénateur de de Wallis et Futuna et
Michael coulis
sans sans écorché tendance chers
collègues est avec nous ce matin et
j'imagine que nos sénateurs ultramarins
réagiront à vos différentes
interventions mesdames et messieurs donc
maintenant je vais passer la parole à
Madame Stéphanie Genex rabot qui nous
présentera qui va nous présenter le
projet donc Petit Campus donc vous êtes
l'invité surprise de ce matin je crois
puisque nous n'avions pas nous nous
avions pas dans nos radars donc nous
sommes ravis de vous retrouver ce matin
et je vous laisse la parole donc pour
Petit Campus
merci
bonsoir bonjour ou très bon matin à
toutes et tous eu l'étendue des créneaux
horaires qui nous rassemblent
aujourd'hui merci à madame la Présidente
mesdamesynatrices et monsieur le
président de la délégation sénatoriale
aux outre-mer d'avoir associé
l'université de la Nouvelle-Calédonie à
ce panel je sais qu'il y a eu des petits
soucis de circulation
d'informations et donc on a toutes et
tous reçus les précisions un peu
tardivement mais j'espère néanmoins que
le dispositif effectif que je vais vous
présenter au sein de l'université de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie va apporter un
éclairage complémentaire aux questions
que vous serez amené à traiter
aujourd'hui merci chers collègues
Isabelle pour ce propos introductif fort
intéressant comme toujours je vous
arrête deux secondes parce que soit il y
a beaucoup de vent
en Nouvelle-Calédonie soit vous touchez
un micro
puisque je vais essayer de couper la
clim ah c'est peut-être là que voilà
nous on a pas besoin forcément de clim
aujourd'hui
j'ai une clim mécanique
est-ce que c'est mieux on va le voir à
l'usage mais je pense oui merci Madame
d'accord donc le dispositif Petit Campus
il a été initié en
2020 peut-être pour donner une idée de
notre échelle
universitaire l'université de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est deux campus un
campus basé à Nouville
dans Nouméa dans le sud de la Grande
Terre et puis un autre campus à Baco à
l'extrême nord environ 300 km de
distance donc deux campus un au sud un
au nord et puis en 2023 c'était environ
4000 étudiantes et étudiants qui étaient
inscrits sur ces deux campus pour avoir
un ordre d'idée de l'échelle dans
laquelle on évolue c'est une un projet
qui a émergé en mai 2020 ensuite à une
demande d'étudiante qui que c'est
enceinte de 7 mois et qui était
fortement démunie et qui envisageait de
d'interrompre ses études universitaires
alors qu'elle était particulièrement
brillante et en phase de d'obtenir son
diplôme de Licence donc elle s'est
orientée vers la chargée de mission vie
étudiante de l'époque Madame Brigitte
Gustin pour lui faire part de ces
difficultés de ces questionnements et de
ses doutes et pour répondre à ça demande
il y a eu un élan de solidarité pour
l'accompagner dans la suite de ces
études et c'est de de cette demande
particulière qui est née l'idée de
déployer un dispositif à plus grande
échelle à l'échelle de l'université qui
pourrait justement répondre aux besoins
des étudiantes et des étudiants en
particulier quand
quand ils sont parents de jeunes parents
ou quand ils sont quand il faut
concilier études et parentalité parce
qu'on s'est on s'est aperçu après cette
demande spécifique que 9 fois sur 10 les
étudiantes décident d'abandonner leurs
enfants un faute d'autres alternatives
la seule alternative qui se présente à
elle c'est de devoir confier leurs
enfants aux grands-parents ce qui
suppose parfois de les envoyer sur les
îles donc ce qui suppose une rupture
faute de moyens financiers ou faute
d'autres alternatives donc l'objectif du
Petit Campus
c'est d'accompagner les parents quand
ils se préparent à être de jeunes
parents mais aussi quand ils sont déjà
parents pour pouvoir concilier leur
poursuite d'études et là parentalité
Petit Campus c'est donc constitué grâce
à
un des partenariats qui ont été menées
avec des collectivités de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie notamment la province
Sud des associations aussi qui ont
répondu à l'appel de ce projet comme le
Kiwanis Nouvelle-Calédonie par exemple
et puis la fondation universitaire de
l'Université de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui existe depuis 2016 et qui permet
qui peut prétendre au mécénat et grâce
au mécénat cette fondation permet de
déployer des actions innovante des
projets stratégiques portés par
l'université et la mission égalité au
sein de l'université de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie est un axe
stratégique fort pour la précédente
monture et pour la mandature actuelle
donc c'est grâce au partenariats entre
la fondation universitaire des
collectivités et des associations peut
se dispositif a pu se monter dans une
perspective de pérennisation de de cette
outil à disposition des étudiants et
donc il a été inauguré l'année dernière
en avril
2020 cette salle de la de parentalité
Petit Campus elle a aussi été montée
avec le soutien de la Maison de
l'étudiant qui est l'équivalent du CROUS
dans les universités métropolitaines et
donc c'est un local qui se situe juste à
côté de la Maison de l'étudiant à
proximité qui a été mis à disposition
par la maison de l'étudiant donc c'est
une grande pièce
qui est accessible du lundi au samedi de
5h30 à 22h puisque la bibliothèque
universitaire est également ouverte le
samedi c'est une grande salle de
parentalité avec divers accessoires pour
pouvoir concilier un travail étude et
présence de l'enfant ou qui peut
permettre aussi de se réfugier dans une
salle plutôt intime pour pouvoir
allaiter pour pouvoir tirer son lait et
pour pouvoir le conserver dans un frigo
donc il y a dans cette salle
à différents accessoires des lits à
barreaux des lits pliable
des chaises hautes des transats des
tapis d'éveil une table à langer pour
pouvoir changer bébé
il y a également une grande table pour
pouvoir étudier avec un ordinateur à
disposition et puis un accès aux wifi
pour pouvoir voilà être avec bébé tout
en tout en étudiant
jusque tard le soir ou certains
s'amus en parallèle des trousseaux de
linge sont proposés aux jeunes parents
dans une démarche un peu éco-citoyenne
l'idée était de proposer par âge des
trousseaux de linge de serviettes
d'accessoires de literie qui sont
ensuite
remis à d'autres jeunes parents donc des
trousseaux de 0 à un mois de un mois à
trois mois
de 0 à 6 mois qui permettent de soutenir
aussi les étudiantes et les étudiants
qui sont parfois dans des situations de
grandes précarité économique et de
fournir un trousseau de première
nécessité en fonction de l'âge de
l'enfant pour pouvoir
l'équiper dans un dans un premier temps
depuis la création de petits campus
c'était chaque année une dizaine
d'étudiantes qui
bénéficiait de ce de ce dispositif
depuis la rentrée universitaire donc en
février 2023 ce sont deux étudiants qui
occupent cette salle Petit Campus de
façon régulière parfois les mercredis
après-midi parfois le samedi dans la
journée
pour pouvoir revenir sur le campus
descendre à la bibliothèque
universitaire et puis passer du temps
avec bébé qui pendant qu'il dort permet
de se dégager du temps dans cette même
pièce pour mener des travaux pour
consulter un certain nombre d'ouvrages
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur sur
Petit Campus en particulier
bien écoutez merci beaucoup je pense
qu'il y aura quelques questions qui qui
auront été inspirées par vos votre
présentation tout à l'heure lorsqu'on va
passer aux questions donc maintenant on
va s'intéresser à la Polynésie française
on voyage beaucoup ce matin je laisse la
parole à Monsieur Louise bastide
sociologue pour une présentation des
spécificités familiales et parentales
pour ce territoire je vous remercie
monsieur c'est à vous
merci de m'avoir invité à parler
alors je vais beaucoup de choses ont été
dites qu'ils vérifient c'est un peu
brouillé votre propos est un peu
brouillé donc est-ce qu'il y a un
réglage qui pourra peut-être être fait
différemment pour que ce soit plus clair
[Musique]
les choses
est-ce que ça va mieux
attendez alors là allez-y
bon certains disent oui d'autres on
verra l'usage cher monsieur
[Musique]
donc je disais que beaucoup de choses
ont déjà été dites sur les structures
familiales qui se retrouvent évidemment
en Polynésie française donc je vais
aborder les points qui n'ont pas encore
été
abordés
donc on a effectivement cette structure
qui est distribuée en Polynésie
française entre la grande famille on
appelle le fait ici et puis la famille
conjugale la famille conjugale donc le
couple et ses enfants et on observe on
observe en fait donc due aux éléments
qui ont été mentionnés déjà c'est à dire
d'une part l'intervention des églises à
un moment donné et puis ensuite
la globalisation de l'information des
productions culturelles et puis le fait
que beaucoup de familles sont métissés
aussi on est dans un moment où la femme
les familles sont mises en tension entre
ces différents modèles quelque part
et cette mise en tension on la retrouve
notamment
chez les plus jeunes générations avec
une certaine aspiration
se replier en partie sur la sphère
conjugale par rapport
par rapport aux parents
donc
ceci dit la famille élargi continue à
avoir un rôle très important très
important en Polynésie française alors à
la fois parce que elle continue d'être
porteuse de de liens affectifs
c'est-à-dire qu'on tient aux relations
dans la grande famille mais aussi elle a
une base matérielle extrêmement
importante et beaucoup d'individus
continuent à dépendre très fortement de
la grande famille tout simplement pour
quelque part leur survie économique
donc sa Polynésie française c'est un
territoire qui est extrêmement
extrêmement cher où on a un taux de
pauvreté monétaire
important et donc on a beaucoup de
personnes pour lesquelles la famille la
grande famille elle va permettre de de
pallier ces déficits notamment ce
déficit au niveau économique la grande
famille c'est aussi des rapports de
solidarité qui joue beaucoup alors je
prends juste un exemple assez simple la
Polynésie française est évidemment un
territoire qui est extrêmement éclaté
géographiquement
qui est caractérisé par une très forte
polarisation autour de Tahiti pour
l'accès à toutes sortes de biens y
compris les emplois d'ailleurs
mais aussi pour accéder à la scolarité à
la scolarisation etc donc on est sur un
territoire très éclaté sur lequel les
personnes ont une quasi obligation de
migrer pour venir à Tahiti ou pour
d'autres raisons pour partir dans les
villes et ces migrations bien souvent
elles ne sont réalisables que dans le
cadre familial parce qu'autre rement
elle serait beaucoup trop onéreuse donc
on est allé on a à la fois obligé de
circuler mais dans cette circule dans le
cadre de cette circulation on ne peut
bouger
quelles conditions de bouger le long des
réseaux familiaux donc ce que je veux
dire en fait ce à quoi ça aboutit c'est
finalement à une très grande dépendance
des individus vis-à-vis de ce cadre
familial
donc on a en métropole on a enfin l'aide
sociale les différentes prestations
sociales sont aussi
conçus de manière à permettre
aux jeunes de s'émanciper de la famille
alors c'est quelque chose qui est très
difficilement possible ici en Polynésie
française
l'idée c'est pas de dire que les gens le
veuillent particulièrement mais dans le
cas où on le voudrait c'est extrêmement
compliqué donc on a cette très forte
dépendance vis-à-vis du cadre
familial alors sur le la question du fin
hameau donc le transfert des enfants
donc Isabelle leblic on a parlé tout à
l'heure alors moi il faut savoir que
j'ai abordé ces questions au départ par
le biais de recherche qui portait sur
les violences familiales les violences
intra familiales donc c'est un angle qui
est un peu particulier aujourd'hui on a
des programmes de recherche qui nous
amènent à travailler sur les
transformations de la famille
contemporaine donc ils vont nous donner
d'autres pers
mais de ce que j'ai vu pour l'instant
alors d'abord ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que c'est le phare le phare a donc
l'adoption coutumière si on veut
c'est un phénomène qui est installé et
qui persiste et qui ne baisse pas en
fait l'inaid a fait récemment des études
là-dessus une étude très récente l'an
dernier je crois qu'elle a été publié
qui montre effectivement qu'on est dans
une certaine stabilité
donc ce que montre cette étude c'est que
le fait de donner un enfant concerne 11%
des femmes de plus de 35 ans
et 20% des femmes de plus de 50/50
reçoivent chez elle des enfants qui sont
considérés comme des enfants enfin
alors comme le disait Isabelle leblic
cette institution le motif au transfert
d'enfant les motifs sont multiples c'est
vraiment très c'est vraiment il y a
plein de raisons à ça et ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que les motifs sont
encore plus hétérogènes qu'avant
donc à la fois les motifs c'est à dire
que par exemple on a des situations de
difficultés économiques qui vont pouvoir
amener une femme ou un couple a confié
son enfant première chose deuxième chose
l'enfant est parfois confié en dehors du
fait Hills qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant donc en dehors de la famille
élargie donc on a une multiplicité de
formes de fin à mou et ce qui fait le
comment entre ces différentes formes je
pense aujourd'hui c'est
et bien la légitimité sociale qui existe
au fait de confier de transférer un
enfant donc c'est quelque chose qui est
socialement qui est pas socialement
dévalorisé donc c'est une option qui
existe dans des situations de vie qui
peuvent être compliquées par ailleurs
donc voilà si vous lorsque les gens vous
parlent d'une femme aujourd'hui n'est
pas un mot hein ce qu'on vous dit bien
souvent c'est que les anciens vous
disent qu'en fait c'est plus d'une femme
aujourd'hui on est dans quelque chose
d'autre puisque les motifs traditionnels
sont plus le support à toutes les à tous
les transferts d'enfants donc voilà donc
ça continue à se produire c'est une
institution très importante dans la
société polynésienne et j'ai envie de
dire c'est un le transfert d'enfance
passe très bien la plupart du temps ça
se passe très bien donc nous du point de
vue de nos enquêtes qui portaient sur
les violences familiales on peut dire en
revanche que on a une sur-reprétation on
a fait une enquête quantitative sur
cette question des enfants enfin amour
dans
les violences familiales d'accord à la
fois comme victime et auteur mais c'est
quelque chose qui est un peu biaisé
puisque les victimes ont plus tendance à
être auteur aussi on sait pas bien faire
la part des choses
en tout cas ça existe et alors ce qui
est peut-être important à dire et ça
c'est un élément très très important
sur le fenwhy ici en Polynésie française
c'est
le rapport de la famille à la terre aux
terres familiales donc contrairement à
la Calédonie les Polynésiens n'ont pas
été spolié de leur terre et donc les
familles les familles les familles et
élargies
disposent de terre en général par le
biais de la famille élargile un individu
un potentiellement des prétentions sur
des terres à différents endroits
d'accord et cette terre elles sont
détenues
elles sont détenues de manière
collective en indivision ce qui est un
facteur majeur de conflits donc
utilitaire qui dit un division dit aussi
héritage et l'enfant pas amour il vient
se placer dans la question de l'héritage
et ça c'est un vecteur de tension
majeure dans les fratries souvent
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
souvent on a les moi j'ai parlé à
beaucoup d'enfants enfin un mot et à des
parents enfin vous et à des des frères
et des sommes enfin à nous et ce qui se
produit très souvent c'est que la
différence est gommée alors jamais
totalement parce que l'enfant a un
mousse est souvent soit l'enfant le plus
chéri soit un peu l'enfant le moins cher
et dans les familles et alors même dans
les familles égalités si on veut quelque
part où on fait pas de différence entre
les enfants ben souvent cette différence
entre l'enfant un mot et les enfants
biologiques elle va ressortir au moment
où les biens familiaux entre en jeu donc
notamment au moment de l'héritage
donc voilà et puis alors on Polynésie
française je veux dire le droit est pas
du tout équipé pour gérer la question du
fin à mou il l'a a passé par le droit
civil donc à trouver sa place dans les
formes d'adoption qui sont des formes
d'adoption française européenne donc on
bricole ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
bricole et en fait en Polynésie il
existe aussi quelque part un dualisme
des normes de fait sinon en droit
c'est-à-dire que la coutume continue à
être active et bien souvent vous allez
des enfants qui vont être
qui vont être fait un mot comme on dit
mais pour lesquels ça va jamais être
formalisé en droit non plus
et là qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que
vous êtes face à des enfants qui ont un
statut juridique très ambigu
et ce statut juridique comment il va
être géré et ben il va être géré par les
opérateurs de terrain c'est à dire les
gens de la protection de l'enfance les
profs à l'école les gens du milieu
médical
normalement lorsque vous amenez à un
enfant qui est pas le vôtre pour faire
soigner
vous avez des difficultés c'est pas
possible a priori or tout le monde fait
en sorte que ce soit possible sachant
que juridiquement ça n'est pas fondé
donc vous avez des opérateurs de terrain
qui en fait prennent un risque juridique
en parce que tout simplement il s'agit
de reconnaître cette institution
polynésienne on peut pas dire ça existe
pas et puis on peut pas dire c'est pas
bien quoi donc vous avez beaucoup
d'opérateurs à la protection de
l'enfance etc qui font comme si le
parent qui n'a pas été en droit
identifié comme le parent légitime de
l'enfant et m'a été son parent donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on a vu beaucoup
puisqu'on a fait des enquêtes avec
les acteurs des milieux
dans les domaines du social et du
médical et c'est quelque chose qui vient
qui revient de manière récurrente donc
c'est géré finalement par des individus
et ça a une autre application l'autre
application c'est que
l'aménagement du fin amour a et bien il
est très dépendant de la politique
pénale du moment c'est à dire rien nous
dit qu'à un moment donné on peut pas
avoir un procureur qui nous disent ah
bah on veut plus du fin à mou ça cause
trop de problèmes donc simplement on va
plus accepter de les intégrer dans
l'adoption
d'accord
donc voilà c'est des problématiques qui
sont qui sont assez vives sur le
territoire enfin sur les aides sociales
donc c'est ça vous m'excuserez je fais
ça un peu en vrac pendant que j'essaye
d'ajouter des choses qui n'ont pas déjà
été dites
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les
prestations sociales sont modestes en
Polynésie française mais néanmoins
critique pour les familles
qui les touches
en gros
le rapporter
la dépense par habitant
les dépenses sociales par habitant en
métropole sous s'élève à 1700 euros
à 1700 euros
lorsqu'elle s'élève à 630 euros en
Polynésie donc c'est beaucoup plus bas
alors que les besoins sont probablement
bien plus importants
d'où le fait notamment c'est une des
explications qui permet de comprendre à
quel point les individus sont dépendants
du cadre familial pour accéder à toutes
sortes de ressources
alors il y a un élément peut-être je
vais pas m'étendre sur le paysage
institutionnel parce que je vous
donnerai une image partielle c'est
quelque chose que je maîtrise pas
suffisamment mais sur notamment sur les
allocations familiales un élément
intéressant c'est que
les allocations familiales dans le cadre
du régime des salariés
s'élèvent à 10000 francs pacifiques par
mois et par enfant et dans le cadre du
régime social elle s'élève à 7000 francs
par enfant donc on voit ce qui est
complètement paradoxal puisque
finalement les familles en plus grandes
difficultés
qui sont inférieures aux personnes qui
sont en emploi
[Musique]
je m'arrête là je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
complète et très intéressante aussi
comme les précédentes d'ailleurs sur sur
les spécificités de la Polynésie
française alors du coup il nous reste
une intervenante c'est Madame Rodica
Linka je vous me direz si je j'ai bien
prononcé je ne crois pas j'ai vu votre
visage qui a dit non donc c'est pas la
bonne prononciation toutes mes excuses
madame et j'ai donc je vous laisse la
parole pour le soutien à la parentalité
en Polynésie française alors dites moi
comment on prononce
très bien ah ben écoutez vous savez la
parole on vous écoute attentivement
depuis la salle de réunion du Sénat
voilà bonjour à toutes et à tous
j'aborderai le soutien à la parentalité
et pour la beauté je commencerai par
présenter l'origine des besoins des
parents et les besoins exprimés par les
parents ou const nous avons mené sur le
terrain des entretiens et des
observations l'origine des besoins est
ancrée en premier lieu dans l'évolution
de la structure familiale dans le
fonctionnement homogène ça a été
présenté par mon collègue en famille
élargi vers l'individualisation qui
conduit les familles polynésiennes à
modifier en quelque sorte que le mode de
vie et la modification de mode de vie
entraîne des nouveaux besoins il a
nécessité d'en accompagnement le passage
donc d'une société rurale d'auto
subsistance qui est présente encore dans
les dans les archives éloignées à une
société où le rémunérer est stable et
valorisée entraîne le départ
l'immigration l'exode voilà des îles
éloignées vers Tahiti
si ce départ est influencé aussi par les
médias par les réseaux sociaux il
constitue aussi une stratégie de
certains parents pour éviter la rupture
familiale par le départ précoce de leurs
enfants pour poursuivre des études
parfois un très jeune âge donc ça veut
dire déménager à Tahiti ou alors ils
élabore d'autres stratégies comme
l'instruction à domicile par exemple
les études sur l'application parentale
dans la scolarité des enfants note une
différence d'implication liée au milieu
social d'appartenance et à la situation
économique donc les données de
l'institut de statistiques de la
Polynésie française indiquent 60 % des
Polynésiens des Polynésiens vivent sous
le seuil de bas revenu métropolitain
donc de façon relative la pauvreté et
plus importante qu'un métropole 26% des
Polynésiens vivent sur le seuil est
devenu contre 14 il me semble en
métropole donc les mutations sociales et
la fragilité économique des familles
génèrent d'autres phénomènes tout aussi
préoccupants comme le comportement à
risque surconsommation d'alcool des
drogues sexualité non protégées rupture
de l'infamilio carence affectif
défaut de soins de
décrochage échec scolaire violence entre
familiale
donc tous ces situations limitations
nécessitent peut-être des dispositifs
spécifiques de l'aide à la parentalité
on distinguera des besoins à la
parentalité orientée vers la famille
connaissant des difficultés énoncées et
des besoins d'accompagnement à la
parentalité des parents ordinaires
où en est-on en fait en Polynésie
française par rapport aux dispositifs et
aux besoins
des études de rapport les dernières
années témoignent que la Polynésie est
très sensible et attentive aux besoins
de la famille et plus particulièrement
des parents en situation précaire bon ça
veut pas dire que tout est fait mais il
y a déjà une
grande attention qui est accordée aux
besoins de la famille pour donner des
quelques exemples on était mené des
travaux pour la définition d'un plan
d'action au plus proche des besoins des
Polynésiens et d'une politique de
prévention à la délinquance et notamment
avec des dispositifs des prises en
charge d'accompagnement par la tasse le
service social de la Caisse de
Prévoyance Sociale la CPAS l'office de
polynésien de l'habitat les services de
la santé les associations ou bien
d'autres partenaires dans notre côté le
ministère de l'Éducation a mis en place
une plateforme d'accueil de déclencheur
dans certains communes pour informer les
parents et les décrocheurs une mission
de lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
en matière de prévention en référent de
décrochage a été désigné dans chaque
établissement en groupe de prévention de
décrochage scolaire a été installé dans
chaque établissement des actions de
lutte contre l'absentéisme
l'important s'accorder ou décrochage il
est à notre dispositif
[Musique]
pour les enfants de 6e pour qu'il puisse
rester plus longtemps dans leurs îles
avant de quitter les familles
l'important c'est accorder au décrochage
ressort également de la charte de
rééducation ou des objectifs sont
consacrés à la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire en faveur de la
persévérance scolaire et qui sont
déclinés dans des actions où les la
présence des parents pour l'importance
des parents et clairement expliciter
impliqué encore les parents d'élèves
donner des réponses aux parents
également dans le même sens il s'agit de
réorganiser des transports scolaires
toujours dans la même dynamique
dans notre côté on a les associations
qui proposent des séances de soutien à
la parentalité
les plus actifs les plus actives et
visibles la Maison de l'enfance qui
propose des ateliers en direction des
parents en partage d'outils de la
parentalité positive
qui est disponible dans plusieurs
communes de Polynésie l'association Agir
pour l'insertion
aussi des formations de soutien dans la
parentalité sur des périodes assez
longues parfois sur deux mois avec deux
séances hebdomadaires des dispositifs
multiples
portaient par les mairies en
collaboration avec des associations
comme le projet éducatif local qui vise
à favoriser la réussite éducative des
jeunes issus des quartiers prioritaires
parents autrement à Tahiti une
association qui a pour but de promouvoir
une éducation
en ligne qui propose des fiches des
outils des livres des vidéos
je finis par les prendre à la question
le soutien à la parentalité doit les
spécifiquement les parents d'enfants en
situation de décrochage scolaire ou on
privilégie plutôt une approche globale
selon les recherches menées nous sommes
pour privilégier une approche globale
dans le sens où tous les parents peuvent
manifester le besoin d'un soutien
à la parenthèse à la parentalité mais la
diversité des situations rencontrées
appellent différentes solutions
parfois il s'agit de prévention de
décrochage mais parfois il y a besoin
des dispositifs de rapprochage des
jeunes afin de le permettre de finir la
formation des dispositifs
d'accompagnement des parents ayant des
enfants a besoin en particulier des
parents manifestants manifestants des
besoins liés au contenu de savoir
enseigner à l'école des parents
n'expriment pas des besoins pour
diverses raisons mais en les éprouvant
juste pour donner quelques exemples si
c'est un dispositif d'aide à la
parentalité existe à Tahiti notamment
les associations que j'ai citées ils
sont moins présents voire absent dans
les archives et les loignées donc en
besoin numéro 1 je dirais que il
faudrait mettre en place des dispositifs
dans les îles
une approche plus fine de la situation
indique que les besoins des parents ne
sont pas les mêmes selon qu'ils habitent
à Tahiti ou dans les archipels éloignés
donc le besoin d'eux c'est des
dispositifs adaptés à la situation en
facteur défavorable dans une situation
n'est pas si défavorable dans une autre
situation en référence je dis cela en
référence aux facteurs qui permet
d'établir l'indice de défavorisation
comme le diplôme de la mer la fratrie
l'habitat le type de famille nucléaire
ou élargi emploi du père le type de
contrat
sans devenir sur les concepts
d'autosuffisance ou de pauvreté
un autre aspect que je souhaiterais
discuter il y a à l'impact des
dispositifs combien de parents en
nécessité ou en besoin sont touchés qui
sont ses parents
ou ont lieu ces sessions
d'accompagnement parentales
concernant les dispositifs cités
surtout
qui participent aux ateliers proposés
par les associations nous sommes
généralement en présence des parents
volontaires et des vendeurs
son volontaire les parents qui sont déjà
impliqués dans l'éducation de leur
enfant ceux qui viennent déjà à l'école
qui n'ont pas peur de l'école du
dialogue avec le maître
souvent le nombre de places dans ces
formations qui sont proposées et
limitées
de l'association ou bien à l'école alors
que sur les vallées de Tahiti éloignés
bon les parents ne vont pas se déplacer
ni à l'école ni dans les associations
pour les formations en ligne l'accès au
site pour télécharger les fiches et
limiter des adhésion or les familles les
plus en besoin non pas d'habitude accès
au numérique donc le besoin de toi
serait des dispositifs des formations
accessibles pourquoi pas des dispositifs
itinérants qui vont chez les parents qui
en ont le plus besoin dans un premier
temps après ils découvriront le
dispositif et espérons qu'ils vont se
déplacer à l'association ou sur le lieu
de la formation de la sensibilisation du
type de dispositif qu'on met en place
d'autres aspects peuvent orienter le
type de dispositif à mettre en place
mais peut-être je pourrais les aborder
leur des discussions il s'agit notamment
des aspects qui tiennent au
représentations que les parents ont de
l'école je vous remercie
et bien écoutez merci beaucoup madame
pour avoir donné quelques précisions
nouvelles aussi avec ces propositions de
solutions
d'itinérance notamment alors avant de
passer la parole aux rapporteur
peut-être je voudrais juste dans vos
questions et Stéphane bien entendu le
président Stéphane Artano qui à distance
s'il souhaite d'ores et déjà intervenir
va nous le faire savoir
lorsqu'on a parlé de transfert d'enfants
notamment au niveau de la Polynésie
française est-ce que vous pourrez
peut-être nous donner des chiffres pour
savoir s'ils existent d'ailleurs pour
savoir si ça ce que ça représente par
rapport au nombre de naissances et moi
j'avais une question un peu parce que
j'ai eu un doute sur ma compréhension
sur lorsque vous avez parlé de de
transfert d'enfants de confiage
d'enfants et vous avez fait un lien avec
les violences familial victimes ou
auteurs j'ai pas très bien compris
si
ces transferts étaient à l'origine de
violences intrafamiliales parce que ça
crée des problématiques ou est-ce que
les enfants transférés étaient dans un
état de de de colère ou de stress et du
coup était impliqués il y a des micros
qui font beaucoup de bruit là si vous
pouvez tous couper vos micros s'il vous
plaît
donc si les victimes aussi les enfants
étaient étaient
finalement pour quelle raison ils
avaient un rôle dans ces violences
intrafamilales donc ça c'est une
première question qui de compréhension
je souhaitais dont je souhaitais vous
faire part sur l'opération Petit Campus
j'avais aussi je voulais savoir si
c'était quoi le budget
comment il était réparti et est-ce que
il y avait pas des possibilités plutôt
de de garde d'enfants sur le camp qui
aurait pu être des solutions aussi
peut-être plus facile pour pouvoir
aller en cours ou à la bibliothèque de
manière plus large et plus plus souple
on va dire j'avais une question sur
puisque ça a été évoqué par les premiers
intervenants sur l'église et je voudrais
savoir si dans tous les territoires la
religion puisque il n'y a pas que
l'Église et la religion catholique
quelle place à l'église ou et la
religion en général dans la parentalité
et est-ce que elle a la même place
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'avait
auparavant donc ça c'est une autre
question et je vais peut-être m'en
arrêter m'arrêter là pour laisser les
deux si vous pouvez noter les questions
et peut-être laisser le président Artano
et les deux rapporteurs posés les
questions on va prendre toutes les
questions en même temps là et après on
passera la parole au sénateur et
sénatrice qui sont en salle avec nous
pour qu'ils puissent aussi poser des
questions donc je vais passer la parole
à notre collègue et président Stéphane
Artano qui est à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et ensuite les
deux rapporteurs donc merci de noter
toutes ces questions mesdames et
messieurs pour pouvoir y répondre de
manière ordonnée tout à l'heure merci
merci cher Annick deux questions très
rapide avant de laisser la parole à nos
autres collègues rapporteurs je crois
que c'est Monsieur bastide qui évoquait
le sujet qui m'a et ça m'a interpellé
notamment par rapport au processus
justement
au processus d'adoption aux conférence
d'enfants est-ce que vous pensez que
dans ce cadre-là il faudrait avoir des
dispositifs d'adoption
qui tiennent compte notamment des
pratiques locales constatées sur le
territoire parce que souvent ce que
j'observe et la remarque que vous avez
formulée par rapport à une attitude d'un
parquet qui pourrait considérer
effectivement qu'on cesse notamment le
confiage d'enfants on voit bien que la
sociologie d'une pratique d'adoption est
peut-être un peu différente en Polynésie
qu'elle ne l'est dans les arômes et j'ai
envie de dire durale l'ex 7 lettres et
malheureusement la loi en matière
d'adoption elle est transversale à tout
nos territoires donc est-ce que ça veut
dire par exemple moi je pense que parce
que je je connais un couple qui a été
confronté donc pour le coup et qui s'est
heurté effectivement à la loi française
dans un cadre sociologique un peu
différent et est-ce que dans à cette
occasion il ne savait pas souhaitable
d'adapter un des dispositifs qui
tiennent compte de ces pratiques et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est là pour
vous écouter aujourd'hui donc ça c'est
Monsieur bastide qui l'a soulevé ça
m'intéresserait d'avoir votre point de
vue là-dessus là c'est pas un point de
vue juriste c'est vraiment un point de
vue qui qui s'inspire de du constat
sociologique que vous avez opéré et puis
je crois que c'est Madame reliquat
linkai j'espère que je l'ai bien
prononcé également
qui a parlé des dispositifs itinérants
moi je serai intéressé également de
savoir si d'ailleurs de manière
transversale sur l'ensemble de vos
territoires vous avez des fédérations
nationales qui existent dans les agones
qui viennent en appui des acteurs locaux
où est-ce que vraiment ce sont des
solutions locales qui ont été mises en
oeuvre par des acteurs locaux parce
qu'on essaye de voir également au
travers ce rapport c'est si finalement
il n'existe pas des freins par exemple
parce que des fédérations de parentalité
dans l'Hexagone interviennent dans les
territoires aux côtés des acteurs locaux
et donc je suis intéressé de savoir si
vous avez aussi identifié ce besoin ou
si la mise en place de dispositifs
propre à chacun des territoires peut se
faire avec les acteurs déjà présents sur
les territoires et uniquement ces
acteurs là aussi on doit élargir ou
donner une possibilité d'élargissement à
d'autres acteurs dans cette question je
me fais l'écho de ce que Madame vient de
dire mais également posé aux autres aux
autres intervenants bien évidemment et
j'en ai terminé
[Musique]
parce que quand il y a quatre
générations alors qu'elles sont quel est
l'intérêt à parler économique est-ce que
pour l'éducation des enfants à part la
transmission des savoir-faire est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment un encadrement
pertinent des enfants concernant le
Petit Campus alors je voudrais également
savoir s'il y a des conventions on fait
comment ça se passe pour les personnes
qui sont concernées et qui en
bénéficient ainsi il y a une convention
est-ce qu'il y a une contrepartie et
puis est-ce qu'il y a déjà eu une
évaluation pour voir si
c'est suffisamment pertinent parce qu'on
est passé dans un premier temps à 10
personnes concernées 10 merde étudiante
à deux alors est-ce qu'il y a eu pour
d'autres étudiants qui a eu que deux
personnes concernées sur l'ensemble du
campus ou est-ce qu'il y a eu une
désertion et pourquoi et l'accès au
numérique également donc les grandes
disparités et là l'accès cet accès c'est
il y a une proposition de notre dernière
intervenante qui disait qu'il fallait
aller vers avec des dispositifs
itinérants mais est-ce que sur
l'aménagement du territoire est-ce qu'il
serait pas plus opportun aussi en même
temps qu'il y ait des mesures prises
pour faciliter à l'ensemble des
personnes concernées et qui en aurait
besoin pour les formations notamment et
pour permettre également une égalité des
chances sur l'ensemble de ces
territoires donc je m'arrêterai là parce
que ma collègue voit également poser des
questions merci beaucoup madame merci
Madame la rapporteur un rapporteur elles
achent merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président à mon
tour de vous remercier enfin de
remercier l'ensemble de nos intervenants
pour la qualité de leur présentation la
complémentarité également qui nous
permet aussi de plonger effectivement
dans les spécificités qui sont les
vôtres et nous voyons bien à quel point
la famille les familles sont traversées
par des grandes mutations ça a été
régulièrement dit notamment avec
l'influence des réseaux sociaux avec
également internet mais vous avez
également à plusieurs reprises soulevées
et insister sur aussi la particularité à
la fois de l'éloignement géographique
mais également de la situation
économique qui peut également venir
bouleverser on le voit bien aussi les
rapports au niveau de la famille et donc
on voit aussi à quel point cette
question de la parentalité elle est au
coeur aussi de la société de son
évolution ce qui m'amène à des questions
parce que je crois et en tant que
législateur nous sommes à la fois très
soucieux en fait du droit que nous
appliquons et nous voyons bien aussi
cette particularité que nous avons ce
matin avec cette table ronde sur à la
fois un droit civil commun mais
également en fait un droit coutumier
vous en avez donné des exemples et des
illustrations notamment à travers la
question
importante de l'adoption mais je voulais
savoir comment s'articule justement en
fait ces deux droits entre le droit
civil et le droit coutumier avec des
notions en fait que nous connaissons
d'autorité parentale par exemple et de
savoir en fait comment les nouvelles
générations
s'approprient aussi ces notions de droit
et ce qu'ils se reconnaissent dans un
droit coutumier ou comment finalement il
s'applient ou est-ce que il y a une
sorte de peut-être de dilution au fur et
à mesure du temps avec les nouvelles les
nouvelles générations peut-être ma
deuxième question qui fait peut-être
plus écho à d'autres auditions que nous
avons pu avoir où on nous a beaucoup
évoqué le développement des familles
monoparentales et le fait que finalement
ça aussi ça modifié
la place et la notion en fait même de
famille donc savoir si dans vos
territoires vous pouvez constater vous
constater cette évolution également de
d'un accroissement des familles
monoparentales de pour un autre
phénomène qui nous a beaucoup été
développés celle des grossesses précoces
avec effectivement des grossesses qui
concernent des femmes de plus en plus
jeunes donc est-ce que vous avez
également sur vos territoires ces
phénomènes là et pour revenir un des
outils qui a été évoqué sur lesquels
mais que là il y avait déjà des
questions qui est Petit Campus je
voulais tout simplement savoir si
l'outil était uniquement destiné aux
femmes ou si finalement en fait des
hommes et des jeunes hommes parents
également étudiants pouvaient également
bénéficier en fait de ce dispositif qui
est effectivement assez intéressant et
novateur je trouve sur la question de la
conciliation entre la vie étudiante la
vie professionnelle mais également la
vie familiale et enfin et j'en
terminerai par là sur la question de la
politique
pénale puisque qui a été évoqué je crois
par l'intervenant de Polynésie est-ce
que vous pouvez peut-être expliciter
lorsque vous indiquez en fait qu'il y
avait une politique pénale des fois à
géométrie variable sur cette question
qui est aussi importante parce qu'on
voit le lien aussi malheureusement des
fois entre la question de la famille
mais également des soucis notamment la
question de la délinquance juvénile je
vous remercie beaucoup pour vos réponses
et bien merci à mesdames les rapporteurs
et monsieur le Président donc je vais
vous laisser répondre à toutes ces
questions comme vous voyez elles sont
déjà nombreuses et j'espère que vous
avez eu le temps de les noter parce que
vous vous organisez comme vous le
souhaitez parce que là on ne voit que le
président Artano à l'écran et je ne vois
pas si quelqu'un alors ouvrez votre
micro si vous souhaitez répondre
pardon
moi je veux bien me lancer
Petit Campus allez
université très bien vous voir
alors pour la première question qui
portait sur le budget du Petit Campus
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée pour
lancer le projet un fond de 800 000
francs qui correspond à environ
6600 euros quelque chose comme ça
a été consacré
au projet
pour pouvoir
rafraîchir à l'espace dédié à cette
salle de la parentalité donc le gros du
Budget a d'abord été consacré
aux travaux de de peinture et de mise
aux normes de cet espace
que la Maison de l'étudiant a mis à
disposition pour pouvoir concrétiser ce
projet de petits campus ce budget il a
aussi été consacré à l'équipement de la
salle de parentalité donc l'acquisition
de de frigo de micro-ondes
d'armoires etc pour pouvoir équiper
cette salle puis ensuite le reste du
matériel
a été donné par des associations
ou par des bénévoles pour constituer les
trousseaux de première nécessité et
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
en présentation pour répondre à cette
démarche un peu éco-citoyenne de
réutiliser du matériel qui était en très
très bon état
et qui est donc mise à disposition de
celles et ceux qui veulent utiliser la
salle de parentalité donc pour limiter
la
consommation et la surconsommation
d'équipements en très bon état
d'usage ça c'était la première question
sur le budget
sur la seconde qui consistait à
réfléchir à un système de garde sur le
campus
ça a été
longuement discuté au départ mais ça
suppose des responsabilités des normes
des assurances qui sont extrêmement
coûteuses et extrêmement complexe à
mettre en place finalement le dispositif
tel qu'il a été construit et tels qui
fonctionnent aujourd'hui
en termes de responsabilité d'assurance
et de fonctionnement aussi puisqu'une
fois qu'on a remis la clé aux demandeurs
et bien ils peuvent aller librement
quand ils ont du temps quand l'espace
est disponible aller dans cette salle
pour pour étudier ou pour tirer leur
lait par exemple on avait même réfléchi
à une application de type blablacar pour
essayer
un système de garde partagée par des
étudiants qui sont parents sur le campus
mais ça n'a pas ça n'a pas abouti voilà
donc ça a été étudié mais l'option
la salle de parentalité s'est avéré la
plus la plus réaliste dans dans notre
environnement qui est celui de
l'Université de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
et puis il y a un autre critère à
prendre en compte c'est que faire venir
des gens pour mettre en garde un système
de garde sur le campus c'est pas
toujours simple parce qu'on est assez
excentré du coeur de la ville on est
environ une dizaine de minutes du
centre-ville pour le campus de nos
villes et puis à partir de 19h 19h15 il
y a plus de navettes de bus alors que
la salle de parentalité elle permet
d'intégrer cet espace jusque 22h le soir
donc l'amplitude horaire est beaucoup
plus importante quand on investit
soi-même le lieu que quand on fait venir
quelqu'un de l'extérieur pour proposer
ce système de garde voilà
pour la question qui portait sur le
conventionnement avec la contractante ou
le contractant il y a effectivement un
système de convention qui est signé
entre la personne qui demande à accéder
à la salle de parentalité la Maison de
l'étudiant et l'Université de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui fixe la durée les
conditions quels sont le ou les
bénéficiaires puisque effectivement si
la demande donc ça c'est pour répondre
aussi en partie à la troisième question
si la demande est
majoritairement formulée par des
étudiantes souvent ce sont les parents
qui viennent occuper cet espace sur une
après-midi ou sur une journée complète
donc ils viennent pas seul dans cette
salle de
mentalité ou alors de façon plus plus
occasionnelle et donc il y a un système
de convention un système de prêt de
Trousseau qui qui tournent avec voilà un
petit état des lieux et puis un
inventeur du linge ou de matériel le
premier nécessité qui est fourni puis
ensuite dès lors qu'il est restitué et
en bon état pour servir à d'autres alors
il est à nouveau remis dans le dans leur
dans le circuit
sur la fréquentation du dispositif
tikampus l'année dernière et l'année
d'avant il y a eu des demandes de 9
étudiantes et de 10 étudiants mais là on
commence tout juste l'année
universitaire on a commencé en février
donc j'ai pas les chiffres de
fréquentation de la salle Petit Campus
sur l'intégralité de l'année
universitaire 2023 puisqu'on vient juste
de commencer qu'on est sur un calendrier
un peu décalé j'espère pouvoir vous
donner des chiffres
actualisés en fin d'année
début décembre 2023 donc là les chiffres
que j'ai annoncé pour 2023 c'est
seulement depuis un mois et demi donc
les deux étudiantes qui vont
ensuite par rapport aux demandes
qui sont d'occupation de cette salle de
la parentalité donc ce sont
majoritairement des étudiants mais il y
a aussi des membres de la communauté
universitaire qui demande de façon
ponctuelle à pouvoir accéder à cette
salle pour pouvoir tirer leur lait en
toute intimité donc c'est son
majoritairement des étudiantes et des
étudiants qui bénéficient de ce
dispositif mais des d'autres membres de
la communauté universitaire investissent
aussi cet espace au cours de leur
journée de travail voilà merci beaucoup
madame
merci beaucoup madame pour ces
précisions alors comme il a été question
je pense notamment des transferts
d'enfants je vais peut-être faire
intervenir pour répondre aux différentes
questions d'abord monsieur Louise
bastide
qui était assez sollicité dans les
questions qui ont été posées par les
rapporteurs
à vous monsieur alors si vous pouvez
allez-y ça beuguait un peu mais allez-y
monsieur
donc je vais essayer de reprendre les
questions donc sur la première question
[Musique]
qui portait effectivement sur la en fait
le statut juridique du transfert
d'enfants
alors ce que je peux dire d'un point de
vue sociologique c'est que quand vous
avez ces deux
ces deux univers normatifs très très
éloignés de l'un de l'autre ça ne peut
que produire des tensions un peu que
produire des tensions et de
l'incompréhension donc je pense
effectivement que si on disposait de
moyens juridiques
de faire voir au transfert d'enfants tel
qu'il est pratiqué en Polynésie
française
ça améliorerait sans doute la situation
et puis je pense que ça aussi un
caractère symbolique qui est important
c'est à dire que c'est une institution
qui est très importante et valorisée
dans la société polynésienne et le fait
de lui donner une reconnaissance quelque
part
droit ce serait aussi je pense quelque
chose
d'intéressant une manière aussi de
reconnaître la valeur de ces
institutions sociales là qui sont
extrêmement importantes dans la
société polynésienne
donc ça me alors ensuite
il y avait une question sur sur la
famille élargie est-ce que la famille
élargie bénéficie
si j'ai bien saisi la question ou au
contraire à des effets délétères
je pense que raisonner de manière
globale on a des cas qui sont très
différents les uns des autres on est
aujourd'hui en Polynésie française dans
une très grande pluralité des modèles
familiaux c'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre on a beaucoup de mal à
déterminer quel est le modèle familial
on aurait beaucoup on a des
configurations familiales qui sont très
très diverses
donc je pense que le vrai le vrai souci
est là peut-être ou la puissance
publique à son mot à dire c'est c'est
que aujourd'hui la vie dans la famille
étendue
ça n'est pas un choix c'est une
nécessité or lorsque vous parlez
aux gens ici on voit très bien que
la plupart des personnes souhaiteraient
bénéficier d'une plus grande autonomie
d'une plus longue grande autonomie
individuelle pour construire sa petite
vie familiale dans le cadre de la
famille conjugale ou en tant qu'individu
donc je pense que ce qui est important
c'est d'aménager le choix
d'aménager le choix pour l'instant les
gens n'ont pas le choix ici non pas le
choix
et ce qui alors lorsqu'ils ont le choix
ce qui se produit c'est pas du tout une
rupture avec la grande famille c'est à
dire que on est en capacité de gérer la
distribution de nos relations entre la
famille conjugale et la grande famille
donc on est dans cette capacité de
mettre à distance ou de se rapprocher en
fonction en fonction des moments tout
simplement
voilà donc c'est quelque chose
effectivement qui en métropole ont
construit l'autonomie médiation des
individus en Polynésie française on est
dans des formes d'individuation aussi
c'est à dire que les jeunes aujourd'hui
ils ont des aspirations individuelles
ils ont pas des aspirations qui se
décrivent tout dans le cadre de la
grande famille et c'est vrai que c'est
très difficile de s'émanciper de ce
cadre là pour beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes
[Musique]
ensuite alors sur la question sur les
modèles familiaux il faut voir aussi je
pense que
les institutions sont elles-mêmes
porteuses de modèles familiaux même si
c'est de manière implicite la manière
dont on va gérer les politiques sociales
la manière dont on va construire l'école
etc tout ça c'est porteur de normes
parentale aussi donc les normes parental
si vous voulez passer la circulation des
normes parentales depuis les modèles
européens jusque en Océanie elle se fait
de tous les côtés en fait et y compris
dans la relation aux institutions
alors pour ce qui est du coup
sur la question de la politique pénale
le problème si vous voulez c'est que
comme c'est on est sur quelque chose qui
n'est pas réglé juridiquement on est on
est quelque part sur des formes de
comment dire
de libéralité quelque part donc on n'est
jamais à l'abri donc je le fais
absolument pas référence à
un moment donné sur la politique pénale
mais nous ne sommes pas là oui
effectivement un moment donné que ça
durcisse et
auquel cas ça
sa problématique beaucoup les relations
quand même avec les familles
polynésiennes donc
si c'était sécurisé juridiquement ça
permettrait peut-être de laisser moins
de l'attitude à la politique pénale et
ça permettrait de décharger les
opérateurs de première ligne d'avoir à
gérer ça dans le quotidien de leur
travail de manière personnelle en
prenant leur risque juridique quelque
part je veux dire quand vous acceptez
que quelqu'un vienne chercher l'enfant à
la sortie de l'école alors que il n'a
pas le lien biologique avec l'enfant et
ça jamais été formalisé par une adoption
par exemple ou une délégation d'autorité
parentale et ben vous prenez un risque
alors sur ensuite sur l'évolution des
alors oui sur le fin à nous encore une
chose puisque la question a été évoquée
sur le fin mou alors pourquoi est-ce que
les enfants sont plus sujets ou violents
on peut faire que les hypothèses nous ce
qu'on sait c'est que c'est le cas on a
réussi on a pu documenter ça mais ce qui
est intéressant de dire aussi c'est que
on retrouve à peu près les mêmes
configurations pour les enfants dans les
familles recomposées donc finalement
entre les enfants par amour et les
enfants dans les familles recomposées on
est on a le même sur risque quasiment
donc ça c'est intéressant déjà on voit
en fait c'est que
et alors sur les familles recomposées il
y a quelque chose de très fort c'est
l'idée que quelque part les enfants des
précédents lits comme on dit ici et bien
souvent sont très mal vécues par le
nouveau couple
donc il y a une forme souvent de mise à
l'écart et d'ailleurs ça peut donner
lieu à mous le fait vouloir écarter
l'enfant du premier livre d'une remise
en couple
voilà c'est pas forcément spécifique
enfin amour hein mais ce qu'on peut dire
quand même c'est que lorsque vous êtes
pas à mou finalement vous multipliez les
acteurs de la parentalité mécaniquement
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir le vu
que on est dans une parenté qui est
additive c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir à
la fois les parents biologiques et les
parents adoptant et bien voilà la
situation sociale dans laquelle
s'inscrivent les relations de
parentalité puis les relations
familiales et bien plus complexe vous
avez plus d'acteurs qui et donc
potentiellement je pense des des
conflits possibles qui sont quelque part
exacerbés notamment et j'ai fait
référence tout à l'heure et c'est une
des hypothèses quand même sur la
question de la dévolution des biens
familiaux quelle est la place de
l'enfant par amour dans la révolution
des biens familiaux et ça c'est quelque
chose que on attribue c'est une question
qu'on a croisé vraiment
de façon fréquente dans nos enquêtes
et alors que
traditionnellement l'enfant va à mou
alors si vous lisez les enquêtes qui ont
été faites à l'époque c'est-à-dire dans
les années 50 si je me rappelle bien
l'enfant va amour ce qui est dit dans
ses études là c'est que il méritait que
dans sa famille biologique aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas l'enfant à nous que
tout à fait être légitime dans sa
famille adoptive
donc sur l'évolution des familles
monoparentales j'ai pas les chiffres en
tête donc je vais pas vous le dire c'est
ce que ce qui est sûr c'est que
la situation des familles monoparentales
et sans doute différente puisque
précisément c'est quelque chose qui
s'inscrit quand même toujours dans le
cadre de la famille élargie alors là il
faudrait avoir des enquêtes un peu
spécifiques et sur les grossesses
précoces de tête en Polynésie française
c'est un phénomène qui est encore
important mais qui régresse qui a
tendance à régresser d'ailleurs le taux
de fécondité on peut une idée française
baisse un baisser de manière très très
rapide dans les dernières décennies
est-ce que vous avez une explication à
cela c'est de la prévention c'est
je
pourrai pas vous donner qu'une
explication satisfaisante comme ça
faudrait que alors il y a plein il y a
plein il y a évidemment il y a le fait
que on soit passé quand même d'une
économie qu'on soit passé de manière
très brutale et ça c'est une spécificité
quand même Polynésie
d'une société traditionnelle à une
société salariale quelque part
et ça c'est quelque chose qui a été
importé sur le territoire par le biais
de l'implantation du centre
d'expérimentation du Pacifique au moment
des essais nucléaires et là on a eu un
boom économique alors d'une violence
inouïe sur le territoire c'est à dire de
façon très très compressée vous avez un
processus de modernisation qui s'est mis
en place
sur
20 ans vous avez une société qui se
transforme dans les grandes largeurs
c'est quelque chose qu'on a sans doute
du mal à comprendre lorsqu'on n'est pas
issu de société pour vécu ça mais c'est
un phénomène qui est extrêmement violent
et qui demande une adaptation des
capacités d'adaptation extraordinaire
donc il y a probablement ce félin dans
une société salariale évidemment le fait
d'avoir beaucoup d'enfants
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout
c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus difficile quelque part
d'accord donc après je sais pas moi j'ai
pas les éléments pour vous répondre
complètement mais je pense que c'est un
facteur éminent
alors on va passer merci beaucoup
monsieur pour toutes ces réponses vous
aviez reçu également tous les
participants à cette table ronde un
questionnaire vous si vous souhaitez
compléter à ultérieurement par envoi de
mail c'est contributions seront les
bienvenus et je pense qu'il y avait
madame
le Blic qui souhaitait intervenir à vous
l'importance du salariat aujourd'hui
en Polynésie encore plus qu'en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et quand même très
centré sur sur Tahiti et je pense que
dans les archipels éloignés comme les
touts à moto ou les Marquis ça beaucoup
moins influence donc il faut pas il faut
il faut garder à l'esprit que le
territoire de Polynésie est quand même
extrêmement vaste extrêmement diversifié
et que donc les
c'est difficile de traiter de la même
façon de l'ensemble
des archipels la deuxième chose c'est
que je sais que par le passé il y avait
eu des expériences de de
décentralisation par exemple de la des
tribunaux qui circulaient dans les îles
je ne sais pas si ça existe toujours et
ça peut être aussi une réponse aussi une
décentralisation de certains
intervenants en milieu
éducatif de l'enfance etc ensuite sur
les fins à mous comme il y a des des
panoramas très diversifiés de faire un
mou
je me demandais s'il a vos études vous
aviez essayé de voir
si certains types de femmes étaient plus
concerné parce que vous dites sur les
violences ou la délinquance etc ou le
malaise que d'autres parce qu'on quand
on parle de parentalité avec le famous
on peut aussi parler de de la gestion
des des personnes âgées et aussi un
facteur dans la famille élargissent
aussi un facteur à prendre en compte
parce que on voit chez nous la misère
des personnes âgées qu'on met dans les
EHPAD parce qu'il y a justement pas de
solidarité familiale dans les sociétés
océaniennes il y a encore de la solidité
solidarité familiale c'est pas forcément
le comment dire la meilleure solution
non plus parce que effectivement les
familles sont isolées manque de moyens
quand vous allez citer les chiffres
madame Malika sur les le niveau des
bastide sur le niveau des prestations
familiales qui sont bien moindres pour
les familles en milieu
ruraux entre guillemets donc face à
l'arrière donc il y a beaucoup de
facteurs qui sont à croiser dans ces
dans ces questions là pour pouvoir les
apprécier de façon
de façon comment dire bien bien
objective et sans parti pris d'une part
et d'autre moi j'avais
à partir de violences familiales de ce
qui forcément
inclus un biais dans l'étude du famous
puisque c'est par les violences
familiales que vous avez abordé les
femmes
moi j'ai pris le moi c'est le pied
inverse c'est-à-dire j'étudie les
adoptions en tant que tel et pas du tout
en tant que que avec un prisme comme ça
comprendre les violences familiales et
le rôle du famous dans la violence
familiale donc voilà je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs questions et qu'il faut mettre
en perspective et qui serait important
de
prendre en compte quoi
merci beaucoup madame pour ces
précisions je vais laisser la parole à
nos collègues qui sont présents aussi
pour compléter les questions et je vous
redonnerai la parole aux intervenants
ensuite alors peut-être
nos collègues des territoires
ultramarins souhaitent-ils poser des
questions je pense à Gérard podjia par
exemple à son voisin Michael Moore
à préciser
au rapporteur que en Nouvelle-Calédonie
il y a il y a vraiment deux statues de
statut le droit coutumier
et le droit commun
et le droit
coutumier à
des particularités
très traditionnel
mais la difficulté que l'on a je dis la
difficulté parce que on est on est
confronté parfois un certain nombre de
soucis sur la terre coutumière si nous
avons aussi nous avons des personnes de
droit coutumier de droit commun mais
aussi sur le foncier foncier on a aussi
le droit commun et le droit coutumier et
donc
je veux juste le préciser ici que dès
lors qu'on est de statut de droite ou du
mieux c'est c'est particulièrement
compliqué
parce que en attendant ça à croire que
c'est du droit commun mais en fin de
compte non même au niveau des tribunaux
nous avons des chasseurs des accessoires
coutumiers
et les tribunaux aussi à cette
particularité d'avoir le droit que tu
mets à gérer ou à juger quoi donc voilà
c'est une particularité qu'il faut
vraiment tenir
on compte de ça
[Musique]
mais ce que je je regrette un peu ici
c'est que
nous avons il nous manque la
seconde partie du des questionnements là
sur les caisses d'aide sociale je sais
pas si vous avez les informations sur ça
oui voilà
parce qu'en fait
je crois
oui
sur les toutes les prestations sociales
évidemment nous sommes très très
intéressés pour connaître les
spécificités de chaque territoire en
termes de de prestations sociales en
termes de différence et en termes aussi
finalement si vous avez des pistes de
réflexion ou des propositions à faire
nous nous les attendons bien entendu
tout à fait tu peux je te laisse à
nouveau la parole chers collègues
merci oui non simplement je voulais
jouer ceci préciser sur ce niveau là
parce que
vous savez que
depuis quelques temps le statut de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans le monde
véritablement changé quoi nous avons des
contenus des compétences
du gouvernement nous avons aussi des
compétences de chaque province et il en
existe trois
mais aussi il y a ce que l'on appelle
couramol la
cafète et donc il y a des compétences
qui sont partagées entre les
collectivités et
les caisses de prestation
familiales aussi donc ça serait
intéressant d'avoir des précisions sur
ça ce que je souhaite simplement à
préciser ici c'est que
c'est tout est centralisé sur le
développement économique
nous avons non seulement le problème de
statut
en Nouvelle-Calédonie mais nous avons
aussi un gros souci sur le développement
économique parce que nous avons une
situation politique actuelle sur le
brainstitutionnel qui n'est pas vraiment
stabilisé
et ça se rajoute
sur nos différents statuts et nos
différentes compétences par collectivité
donc voilà la situation en gros je ne
dis pas que c'est c'est une situation
alarmante mais
mais sur le plan social c'est c'est
assez compliqué c'est assez compliqué
nous avons des soucis parce qu'un
certain nombre de familles chez nous
vivent en dessous de la du seuil de
pauvreté
je
rajoute simplement ici parce que on aura
je crois je dis prochain
[Musique]
pour sur le foncier agricole
la particularité particularité de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est qu'on fait
beaucoup plus
et mieux le développement économique sur
terre de droit commun
sur la terre de droit
coutumier c'est assez compliqué dans la
mesure où les banques
ne viennent pas sur terre
le droit que du mieux parce que le
statut est assez compliqué donc voilà je
veux juste souligner ça mais qui se
répercute effectivement sur sur
le plan familial voilà merci beaucoup
chers collègues je vais céder la parole
à notre collègue de Wallis et Futuna
peut-être monsieur Couly muet ok voilà
lorsque je dis pas Michael devant j'ai
plus de facilité ça fait beaucoup de cas
sinon à vous chers collègues
je pense que tout a été dit par
l'Assemblée territoriale de tout à
l'heure ça a été résumé en gros
par contre si je dois rajouter un peu
compléter une certaine manière comme le
collègue de Nouvelle-Calédonie pour Adja
qui vient de
d'évoquer certains points aussi
spécifiques à la Calédonie évidemment si
on parle d'économie
ça serait ça se répercute un peu aussi
sur le plan social
quant à Z qui se pratique localement qui
sont attribués localement et donc qui
interviennent dans dans le domaine de la
parentalité locale on a nos spécificités
à wallis-phe dans les aides bien sûr du
territoire notamment du sitas et de la
Caisse Locale de retraite qui intervient
en matière sociale bien sûr dans le
l'attribution des aides des allocations
familiales
et tout ça intervient
dans le cadre social au niveau de la
petite enfance
par contre bien sûr
sur un plan social en général si je dois
parler de spécificité
où les espionnat je dirais que
on a la notion de famille qui est très
élargie bien sûr comme on évoquait tout
à l'heure et comme les collègues de
l'Assemblée territoriale
de par le
chargé de mission avait évoqué tout à
l'heure
ça part des parents bien sûr du foyer
classique les parents et les enfants et
autour de ça on a tout le clan puisque
on appelle ça également la famille c'est
la notion élargie de la famille
en Polynésie en Nouvelle-Calédonie tout
est similaire sur le plan familial clan
bien sûr
il y a une petite dizaine d'années on
avait un taux de natalité qui était le
hauteur de 300 licences
par an dans l'année et aujourd'hui on
constate qu'en 2022 on a une baisse très
significative qui est descendu de 300 à
100 naissances en 2022
je pense qu'il y a un gros souci à se
faire sur le plan social et
dans le sur le plan sociologique même
dans le sens où on remarque une
évolution que ça soit sur le plan
économique qui se répercute sur le sur
le plan social
la famille en général maintenant avec
les
jeunes couples
ont tendance à se repérer et donc on
remarque que avec tous ces éléments qui
interviennent en
convergence
on constate une modification des
habitudes et donc
je parle de baisse de la natalité
c'est c'est une intervention des
modifications dans le temps qui
interviennent et qui font que
aujourd'hui on remarque une baisse de la
natalité et aussi une l'exode vers la
nouvelle les olives vers la métropole et
donc tous ces mouvements sociaux sont
causés bien sûr par les difficultés
matérielles les difficultés d'emploi
manquent d'emploi et également de
trouver un terrain d'entente sur un plan
purement personnel sur walyseptuna donc
toutes ces structures sont à améliorer
bien sûr au lycée
si on est bien sûr les plus éloignés
donc les plus enclavés par rapport à
l'Hexagone mais
on se décourage pas on essaye de faire
évoluer les choses positivement au
niveau de l'Assemblée territoriale au
niveau de des deux parlementaires qui
interviennent à Paris et on essaye bien
sûr de faire entendre nos voix auprès de
du gouvernement de manière à améliorer
tout ce qui est amélioré voilà merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup alors avant de
relais c'est la parole des intervenants
s'ils souhaitent réagir je vais laisser
si il souhaite intervenir nos deux
collègues présents ici en salle Bruno
Belin et Jean-Michel Arnaud si vous
aviez souhaité intervenir non a priori
donc je vous laisse vous organiser comme
vous le souhaitez mesdames messieurs
sur pour apporter des réactions ou des
réponses aux intervenants de
wallis-et-futunal sénateur et le
sénateurs de nouvelles Calédonie
notamment qui qui ont voulu vous
interpeller et vous faire part d'un
certain nombre de remarques
comme on a dit qu'il y avait dans
plusieurs territoires une baisse de la
natalité est-ce que on pourra avoir
aussi baisse de la natalité mais à côté
de ça famille monoparentale comment
qu'est-ce que ça représente comment ça
évolue dans les différents territoires
avec lesquels nous sommes en connectés
ce matin à vous madame mesdames
et messieurs si vous souhaitez
intervenir
je crois que Monsieur Louise et Madame
madame allez-y
je vais
oui bien sûr
donc en fait j'ai trouvé quelques
chiffres par rapport à votre question de
tout à l'heure mais les chiffres sont
pas des chiffres de cette année mais les
rapports de l'année dernière il y a 2
ans les sites concernant les enfants et
les enfants biologiques et la famille
monoparentale donc
les enfants
représentent dans l'ensemble 9%
donc 7000 enfants de moins de 18 ans ne
vivent pas avec leurs parents biologie
soit neuf pour cent de la population des
mineurs selon le type de famille ces
populations diffèrent et les deux fois
moins importante chez les couples que
chez les familles monoparentales
cette contre Kens donc ça c'est par
rapport aux enfants après je vous
enverrai après la
l'entretien la conférence je vous en
prie en travail un document que j'ai
trouvé qui porte sur la mémoire qui
porte que sur la
qui propose donc
d'aborder le problème sur plusieurs
angles certainement vous allez trouver
des informations intéressantes voilà
autrement j'avais eu une question
concernant l'intervention des familles
de patron des associations
des fédérations des métropoles dans les
territoires d'ici
en fait sur le plan juridique je ne suis
pas c'est possible parce que même pour
les professeurs des écoles il ne peuvent
pas
professer ici on a encore des cas pour
la Polynésie française aussi les
familles polynésiennes sont très
sensibles au contact avec les
Polynésiens plutôt
par contre les associations peuvent tout
à fait et le font inviter des
spécialistes des psychologues
de métropole pour faire des
interventions locales par rapport donc
à l'intervention de Métropole en
Polynésie voilà c'est tout ce que
j'avais à rajouter merci Madame
je crois souhaiter compléter aussi son
propos
[Musique]
du territoire c'est vrai qu'on a on a
affaire concentration de population sur
Tahiti mais on a les situations qui sont
très différentes en fonction des des
idées des archipel évidemment notamment
et c'est effectivement important de le
noter au niveau de l'intégration dans la
société salariale donc c'est dans les
îles on a des populations Polynésie
française qui sont en capacité aussi de
se maintenir en marge de la société
salariale et notamment la question de
l'autocollant de consommation est
majeure
en Polynésie française
et elle joue un rôle
économique très important au sein des
familles sur le fait un mot évidemment
là aussi je souhaite souligner ce point
j'avais dit que on est dans les formes
extrêmement hétérogènes aujourd'hui que
mon entrée par la voix de la violence
mais qu'évidemment et d'ailleurs c'est
une des enquêtes qu'on avait proposé au
sein de la messhp une requête qui
permettrait de faire une typologie des
formes de de faire un mot contemporaine
pour essayer
de distribuer le suriste de violence sur
ces différentes formes de femmes et voir
effectivement lesquels
fragilisent les enfants quelque part
j'ai pris la précaution aussi tout à
l'heure de dire que bien souvent et même
probablement en majorité enfin nous ça
se passe très très bien
ça se passe très très bien donc voilà je
veux pas être mal compris sur je
voudrais surtout pas laisser l'idée que
le fait amour est une institution
pathologique
bien au contraire
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur je
pense que nous avons
épuisé toutes les questions nous avons
la délégation aux outre-mer et la
délégation au droit des femmes vous a
adressé pour chaque territoire un
questionnaire un peu précis adapté à
chaque territoire si vous souhaitez
éventuellement compléter ces
informations et nous envoyer des mails
avec des données chiffrées également
elles seront les bienvenues je vais donc
clore cette table ronde et passer
peut-être la parole au président Stephen
Artano et vous remercier véritablement
toutes et tous pour vous être connecté
parfois des heures difficiles et pour la
qualité des réponses et la qualité de
vos interventions et dans l'attente de
recevoir d'autres éléments si vous le
souhaitez bien entendu et je laisse mon
collègue Stéphane Artano clôturé cette
table ronde merci à mesdames les
rapporteurs pour leur travail également
en amont de cette réunion merci à vous
[Musique]
à rajouter cher Annick si ce n'est
remercier également nous intervenons sur
la qualité de vos interventions et les
éléments notamment sociologiques très
intéressants que vous avez évoqué et
remercier l'ensemble de nos collègues
qui étaient présents également à vos
côtés à Paris pour cette audition et
donc merci et à très vite bonne fin de
journée à toutes et à tous
bonne journée